BOL.
>> Sean: WELCOME BACK AS WE
CONTINUE LIVE HERE IN
BEAUTIFUL WEST PALM BEACH,
FLORIDA.
NOW TO ANOTHER CRITICAL RITE
RACE RIGHT HERE IN THE --
CRITICAL RACE RIGHT HERE IN
THE SUNSHINE STATE, MARCO
RUBIO OPENED UP A DOUBLE-DIGIT
LEAD OVER VAL DEMINGS AFTER
THIS STRONG DEBATE
PERFORMANCE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE EXTREMIST IN ABORTION
ON THIS CAMPAIGN IS DEMINGS.
SHE'S AGAINST A FOUR-MONTH BAN
AND VOTED AGAINST A FIVE-MONTH
BAN.
SHE SUPPORTS TAXPAYER FUNDED
ABORTION FOR ANY REASON ANY
TIME UP TO THE TIME OF BIRTH.
>> UP OF THE TIME OF
AVAILABILITY.
>> WHAT'S THAT?
THAT'S THE VAGUE LINE IN WHICH
THEY GIVE.
THEY THEN TALK ABOUT THE
DOCTOR AND THE FAMILY.
THE GOVERNMENT IS IN THAT
ROOM!
SHE BROUGHT THEM IN THERE!
SHE WANTS THE TAXPAYER TO PAY
FOR THAT ABORTION.
THAT'S GOVERNMENT INVOLVEMENT.
NOT JUST TO PAY FOR THEM HERE
BUT PAY FOR THEM ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
>> LOOK, THE SENATOR CAN PLAY,
UM, NATIONAL SECURITY EXPERT
ALL HE WANTS.
I KNOW HE NEEDS THAT FOR HIS
NEXT PRESIDENTIAL RUN.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN, I NEED TO
STOP YOU THERE AND I WANT TO
GET -- YOU MENTIONED SENATOR
-- ANOTHER 30 SECONDS FOR THE
SENATOR.
>> I'M THE VICE CHAIRMAN OF
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE AND
THE PREVIOUS CHAIRMAN OF IT SO
IT'S ACTUALLY MY JOB.
MY OPPONENT HAS BEEN IN
CONGRESS FOR HALF A DECADE AND
NEVER PASSED A SINGLE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION INTO LAW.
NOT ONE.
THE ONLY THING SHE DOES IS
VOTE 100% WITH PELOSI.
>> SENATOR RUBIO IS RIGHT.
100% JOE BIDEN VOTER.
100% OF THE TIME.
NOW WANTS TO BE A RUBBER STAMP
FOR CHUCK SCHUMER.
SHE ALREADY SUPPORTS THE BIDEN
AGENDA 100% OF THE TIME LIKE
JOE BIDEN.
SHE DOESN'T HAVE FOND FEELINGS
ABOUT HALF THE COUNTRY.
SHE EVEN CAMPAIGNED WITH A FAR
LEFT ACTIVIST WHO COMPARED
REPUBLICAN VOTERS TO THE
TALIBAN AND AL QAEDA.
DEMINGS PRAISED ON THE
TEACHERS UNION BOSS WHO
TIRELESSLY WORKED TO KEEP YOUR
KIDS OUT OF SCHOOL.
SHE CALLED HER "THE AMAZING
RANDY WINE GARDENER" THE
TEACHER'S UNION HEAD.
SHE PRAISED THE LEFT'S VERY
THOUGHTFUL PLAN TO DISMANTLE
AND DEFUND THE POLICE.
GENIUS MOVE!
LIKE EVERY OTHER RADICAL
DEMOCRAT, SHE SUPPORTS OPEN
BORDERS, WANTS TO LIMIT THE
DOMESTIC PRODUCTION OF OIL AND
GAS, THE LIFEBLOOD OF OUR
ECONOMY THROUGH THE SOCIALIST
NEW GREEN DEAL.
DURING HER FIVE YEARS IN
CONGRESS, ONLY TWO OF HER
SPONSORED BILLS EVER BECAME
LAW.
BOTH RENAMED POST OFFICE
BUILDINGS.
IN CONTRAST --
[LAUGHTER]
-- JUST THE RECORD.
ANY WAY N CONTRAST, MARCO
RUBIO IS ONE OF THE MOST
PRODUCTIVE, THOUGHTFUL,
FREEDOM-LOVING MEMBERS OF THE
UNITED STATES SENATE, LET'S
GIVE A WARM FLORIDA WELCOME TO
SENATOR MARCO RUBIO!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
ANYBODY THAT IS PREPARING FOR
A DEBATE, MAYBE ANY OTHER
CANDIDATES, I PRAY THAT THEY
WATCH THAT DEBATE WITH YOU AND
VAL DEMINGS.
THAT'S MY JOB.
THAT'S WHAT I DO.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A REALLY
GOOD POWERFUL MOMENT FOR YOU
IN THE WHOLE DEBATE.
I THOUGHT SHE DID VERY POORLY.
YOU'RE BOTH UP BY
DOUBLE-DIGITS BOTH RUNNING
AGAINST CANDIDATES THAT ARE
100% OF JOE BIDEN'S POLICIES.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS A
BIGGER CHOICE ELECTION IN OUR
LIFETIME, SENATOR.
>> FIRST OF ALL, WE'RE NOT UP
BY ANYTHING BECAUSE THE VOTES
HAVEN'T BEEN COUNTED.
IT'S IMPORTANT EVERYONE GET
OUT AND VOTE AND RUN THROUGH
THE TAPE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT US TO
DO.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT CHARLIE
CRIST IS BECAUSE HE'S THE ONLY
ONE IN FLORIDA -- WE WERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT THIS A MOMENT
AGO -- WHO WILL HAVE LOST TO
ME IN 2010 AND RICK SCOTT FOR
2014 AND NOW TO RON DESANTIS.
IT'S A RITE OF PASSAGE!
IT'S LIKE THE TRIFECTA.
HE'S THE ONLY CANDIDATE I KNOW
THAT HAD -- THOSE THREE PEOPLE
WERE INTRODUCED ON THE STAGE,
CHARLIE CRIST, RON DESANTIS
AND HIS FAN -- AND CHARLIE
CRIST'S FAN GOT HIS OWN
INTRODUCTION AS WELL.
THE GUY IS NOT A SERIOUS
CANDIDATE BUT I DON'T KNOW HOW
YOU CAN BE WITH NANCI PELOSI
100% OF THE TIME LIKE VAL
DEMINGS IS BECAUSE PELOSI
ISN'T EVEN WITH PELOSI 100% OF
THE TIME SO -- IT'S A TOUGH
THING TO DO.
ANY WAY.
>> Sean: I DON'T THINK JOE
KNOWS TODAY'S THURSDAY.
OUCH, THAT WAS MEAN, RIGHT?
THEY'RE NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR
WHAT I SAY.
YOU KNOW, SENATOR, I LOOK AT
WHAT'S HAPPENED TO THE COUNTRY
-- I WAS AND ASKING THE
GOVERNOR ABOUT THIS THE LAST
20 MONTHS -- MY SON IS HERE
WITH ME TONIGHT.
HE'S 24 YEARS OLD.
HE LIVES IN FLORIDA.
AND I WORRY ABOUT HIS FUTURE.
I WORRY ABOUT MY DAUGHTER'S
FUTURE.
SHE'S 21.
I WORRY ABOUT EVERYONE IN THIS
ROOM, THEIR FAMILY, THEIR
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN'S
FUTURE.
I'VE NEVER SEEN THINGS GET
THIS BAD THIS FAST.
TO ME, THIS IS A VERY -- THIS
IS AN INFLECTION POINT FOR THE
COUNTRY.
AM I OVERSTATING IT?
>> HERE'S WHAT WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND.
THE SAME PARTY THAT HAS IT
IT'S -- A DEMOCRAT PARTY IS
CONTROLLED BY TWO GROUPS,
LAPTOP LIBERALS AND MARXIST
MISFITS.
THAT'S THE CORE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TODAY.
NOT DEMOCRATIC VOTERS BUT THE
LEADERSHIP OF THAT PARTY.
THAT'S WHO THEY TAKE THEIR
ORDERS FROM.
I'LL BE VERY BLUNT, IF THESE
PEOPLE STAY IN POWER FOR
ANOTHER TWO YEARS THEY'LL
DESTROY THE COUNTRY.
IF THEY GET THEIR HANDS ON
THIS STATE OR ANY OTHER STATE,
THEY'LL DESTROY THIS STATE.
I'M GLAD THE GOVERNOR IS HERE
TONIGHT, I ALWAYS SAY THIS TO
PEOPLE, PEOPLE ALL WANT TO
COME TO AMERICA -- ALL OF
THESE GUYS LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
HOW TERRIBLE AMERICA IS BUT
EVERYONE WANTS TO COME HERE.
THEN THE SAME PEOPLE SAY, OH,
BY THE WAY, FLORIDA IS A
TERRIBLE PLACE, BUT THEY ALL
WANT TO MOVE HERE, SO -- UM,
BY THE WAY --
>>
>> Sean: THE GREATEST MOMENT
IN COVID WERE ALL THESE
DEMOCRATS GOVERNORS AND
POLITICIANS THAT SUPPORTED
SHUTDOWNS IN THEIR STATES TO
VISIT YOU DOWN HERE AND THEY
ALL GOT CAUGHT.
>> IT'S A COTTAGE INDUSTRY.
IF I HAD A DIME FOR EVERY ONE
OF THE LOCKDOWNERS, LEFT
LOCKDOWNERS THAT CAME TO SOUTH
FLORIDA, I'D BE A WEALTHY MAN.
THIS HAPPENED OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
>> Sean: THEY GOT CAUGHT
ALMOST EVERY SINGLE TIME.
>> THAT'S THE THING, THOUGH.
WHEN YOUR GREATEST CRITICS --
PEOPLE COULD POSTURE AND EMOTE
POLITICALLY AND SAY THIS STUFF
BUT HOW THEY BEHAVE -- AND
EVEN IF THE WORST CRITICS ARE
COMING TO YOUR STATE, THEN YOU
KNOW YOU MUST HAVE BEEN DOING
SOMETHING RIGHT.
>> Sean: I DON'T KNOW WAS MY
FAVORITE WAS, GRETCHEN WHITMER
WHO CAME AND LIED ABOUT COMING
OR AOC WHO CAME WITHOUT A MASK
ON.
>> MY FAVORITE MOMENT IS WHEN
YOU TALK TO ONE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS AND
INVARIABLY IT COMES DOWN TO,
OH, I'VE BEEN DOWN TO FLORIDA
A BUNCH.
WHY?
MY MOM LIVES IN BOCA.
>> Sean: THAT'S A GREAT
LINE.
LET ME LOOK AT THE OTHER SIDE
OF THIS.
EVERYONE'S TALKING ABOUT A
WAVE ELECTION.
SENATOR, YOU SAID SOMETHING I
HOPE EVERYBODY HEARD LOUD AND
CLEAR.
THERE ARE A LOT OF POLLS BUT
THERE'S ONLY ONE POLL THAT
MATTERS AND THAT'S ON ELECTION
DAY WHEN WE COUNT -- MANY OF
YOU CAN VOTE EARLY.
IN FLORIDA, YOU PERFECTED THE
SYSTEM DOWN HERE THANKFULLY.
IT'S NO LONGER 2,000 OR 2016,
BUT IT'S SO CRITICAL, BECAUSE
LET'S SAY THE DEMOCRATS TOOK
OVER THE SENATE AND THEY HAD A
MAJORITY I DON'T THINK YOU'D
DISAGREE WITH ME, THEY WOULD
PACK THE COURTS AND MAKE
PUERTO RICO -- THEY WOULD
CONTINUE DOWN THIS PATH OF NEW
GREEN DEAL RADICALISM.
IF THAT HAPPENED, I DON'T KNOW
IF WE'D EVER DIG OURSELVES OUT
OF IT.
>> THEY'D ALSO TAKE OVER OUR
ELECTION SYSTEM.
THEY PRETTY MUCH SAID THEY
WANT TO DO THAT.
VAL DEMINGS SAID SHE ALSO
WANTS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO POTENTIALLY TAKE OVER OUR
PROPERTY INSURANCE.
YOU CAN JUST IMAGINE -- MAYBE
THAT'S WHAT THE 87,000 IRS
AGENTS WILL DO?
RUN THE INSURANCE COMPANY.
THE LIST GOES ON THE PARADE OF
HOBBLES THEY WOULD DO.
IF THEY HAD A FILIBUSTER -- NO
FILIBUSTER OR WHATEVER AND HAD
BEEN IN CHARGE OF COVID, THEY
WOULD HAVE LOCKED DOWN THE
COUNTRY.
THEY WOULD HAVE DONE TO THE
COUNTRY WHAT THEY DID TO NEW
YORK, WHAT THEY DID TO
CALIFORNIA, WHAT THEY DID TO
ILLINOIS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WOULD HAVE
DONE.
VAL DEMINGS HAS SAID AS MUCH.
I THINK BOTH DEMINGS AND CRIST
WERE ON RECORD AS LATE AS LAST
SUMMER ASKING FOR ANOTHER
SHUTDOWN IN THE STATE.
THEY WOULD HAVE SPENT
$4 TRILLION.
THEY TRIED TO.
EVEN IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL THEY BRAG ABOUT, ONLY A
QUARTER OF THE MONEY WENT TO
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE REST WENT TO TAKE ON
SERIOUS PROBLEMS LIKE RACIST
ROADS AND DISCRIMINATORY TREES
AND WHATEVER ELSE THAT THEY
CAN THINK OF AND SO -- LOOK,
I'M SORRY.
I HATE TO SAY THIS ABOUT MY
FELLOW AMERICANS BUT THESE
PEOPLE ARE OUT OF THEIR MINDS
AND THEY CANNOT BE ALLOWED TO
BE NEAR POWER.
>> Sean: IT RAISES --
[APPLAUSE]
-- THE BOTTOM LINE, NEWT
GINGRICH DEFINES IT REALLY
WELL, THE NIGHT HE BECAME
SPEAKER, REPUBLICANS WERE OUT
OF POWER 40 YEARS.
I WAS THE EMCEE OF THAT EVENT.
I WAS A LOCAL RADIO HOST IN
GEORGIA AT THE TIME.
HOW DO YOU RECONCILE
CAPITALISM VERSUS SOCIALISM?
HOW DO YOU RECONCILE DEFUND NO
BAIL VERSUS LAW AND ORDER?
HOW DO YOU RECONCILE ENERGY,
DOMESTIC ENERGY PRODUCTION AND
ENERGY DEPENDENCE?
HOW DO YOU RECONCILE
CAPITALISM, SOCIALISM, PUT ALL
OF THESE ISSUES TOGETHER?
THEY'RE VERY DIFFERENT
COMPETING VISIONS.
TO ME, THE ONLY ANSWER IS ONE
SIDE'S GOING TO WIN AND IT
BETTER BE OUR SIDE.
I DON'T SEE ANY MIDDLE GROUND
HERE?
>> YEAH I MEAN, JUST LOOK AT
HOW TO THE STATES HAVE
PERFORMED SINCE I'VE BEEN
GOVERNOR.
YOU HAVE STATES LIKE
CALIFORNIA AND NEW YORK,
PEOPLE ARE FLEEING THOSE
STATES.
THEY'RE NOT SAFE.
THEY TAX, LOCK DOWN, ALL OF
THOSE THINGS.
>> Sean: YOU'RE NOT GIVING
GAVIN NEWSOM ENOUGH CREDIT.
HE'S THE FIRST GOVERNOR IN THE
HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA WHAT HAD
A NET EXODUS OUT OF HIS STATE,
NOT A NET INCREASE.
>> BUT YOU SEE, THOUGH, THE
DIFFERENT, THE FLORIDA
BLUEPRINT HAS WORKED.
PEOPLE JUST BY BRINGING THEIR
WEALTH, THEIR VISITATION,
MOVING HERE, BUT WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO IS TAKE THOSE
FAILED BLUE STATE MODELS AND
THEY WANT TO FORCE THAT OVER
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
SO THEY WANT TO DO THINGS LIKE
MARCO MENTIONED THE ELECTIONS,
THEY WANT TO OUTLAW VOTER I.D.
IN EVERY ELECTION IN OUR
COUNTRY.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF THAT
HAPPENED!
THEY WANT TO MANDATE -- IN
FLORIDA SINCE I'VE BEEN
GOVERNOR, WE BANNED BALLOT
HARVESTING IN FLORIDA BUT THEY
WOULD FEDERALIZE IT AND
REQUIRE BALLOT HARVESTING AND
SO I AGREE WITH MARCO IN THE
SENSE THAT MAYBE WE JUST
DISAGREE ON TAXES OR DISAGREE
ON WELFARE SPENDING... THESE
DIFFERENCES ARE FUNDAMENTAL.
IT'S ABOUT REALLY WHAT IT
MEANS TO BE AN AMERICAN AND
WHAT ARE THE FOUNDATIONAL
PRINCIPLES AND THE LEFT WING
OF OUR COUNTRY HAS DEPARTED
FROM THE PRINCIPLES THAT HAVE
MADE THE COUNTRY GREAT.
>> THEY'RE NOT -- YOU CAN'T
RECONCILE THESE TWO VISIONS.
ONE SIDE HAS TO WIN IN THE
FUTURE OF -- THERE WAS A TIME.
DEMOCRATS WERE A LITTLE LEFT.
REPUBLICANS WERE TO THE RIGHT
BUT WE BOTH OPERATED IN THE
SAME UNIVERSE.
NOW, WHAT'S HAPPENED HERE IS
THESE PEOPLE, THEY LIVE IN
THESE LITTLE BUBBLES LIKE THE
LAPTOP LIBERALS.
THEY LIVE IN THESE LITTLE
BUBBLES.
THE MARXIST MISFITS, NO HOPE
FOR.
THE LAPTOP LIBERALS LIVE IN
BUBBLES.
THEY HAVE THESE IDEAS.
THEY'RE IMMUNE FROM THE
CONSEQUENCES.
SINCE JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN
PRESIDENT, 4.5 MILLION PEOPLE
ENTERED THIS COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY.
THE GOVERNOR FLEW 48 OF THEM
ONE DAY TO MAKE A POINT TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
48.
THEY ARRIVE.
THE STATE OF MASSACHUSETTS
IMMEDIATELY DECLARES A STATE
OF EMERGENCY.
48 PEOPLE.
THEY MOBILIZE 100-SOMETHING
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS, 2-1
RATIO.
THEN THEY DO WHAT ALL THE
LAPTOP LIBERALS DO.
THEY STAGE THIS THING AT THE
CHURCH, GIVING THEM TOYS AND
THINGS, THEN THEY DEPLOY THEM
TO CAPE COD.
IT'S NOT THEIR HOSPITALS OR
CITIES THAT ARE BEING
OVERCROWDED.
THEY'RE MOVING TO IMMIGRANT
AND HISPANIC COMMUNITIES AND
STATES LIKE FLORIDA, TEXAS AND
ARIZONA WHO HAVE TO SHARE ALL
THE BURDEN BECAUSE THE LAPTOP
LIBERALS LIVE IMMUNE FROM THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THEIR
CRAZINESS!
AND THAT'S WHY THEY'RE THAT
WAY.
>> Sean: ONE OF THE AREAS
YOU'RE UNIQUELY QUALIFIED TO
TALK ABOUT IS THE AREA OF
NATIONAL SECURITY.
I'M VERY CONCERNED.
I DON'T THINK JOE BIDEN
GARNERS ANY RESPECT FOR MORAL
LEADERS, HOSTILE REGIMES LIKE
VLADIMIR PUTIN IN RUSSIA,
PRESIDENCY IN CHINA, THE
SAUDI'S MOCKED HIM, MADE FUN
OF HIM AND DENIED HIS REQUEST
TO INCREASE OIL PRODUCTION, AS
A MATTER OF FACT REDUCED IT
AND EXPOSED HE WANTED TO
COLCLUDE WITH THEM TO COLLUDE
WITH THEM TO DELAY THEIR
ANNOUNCEMENT OF THEIR
PRODUCTION AND THE PRODUCTION
OF OIL.
IF IT WAS A REPUBLICAN, THEY'D
BE PUT IN JAIL OR
INVESTIGATED, PROBABLY
IMPEACHED.
>> AS YOU KNOW --
>> Sean: I'M WORRIED ABOUT
THE NATIONAL SECURITY SIDE OF
ALL OF THIS BECAUSE WE SEE
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN UKRAINE,
AND I BELIEVE PRESIDENCY WHEN
HE SAYS HE WANTS TO -- .
>> TO BE FAIR TO BIDEN, AS WE
ALL KNOW SAUDI OIL IS CLEANER
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT THAN
AMERICAN OIL IS SO --
>> Sean: HEADLINE TOMORROW,
MARCO RUBIO SAYS SAUDI OIL'S
CLEANER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> ACCORDING TO BIDEN, SO MY
SOLUTION IS JUST TO PUMP
AMERICAN OIL, PUT A STICKER
THAT SAYS SAUDI AND CONFUSE
HIM AND MAYBE HE'LL BE FOR IT.
GOING BACK TO THE POINT YOU'RE
MAKING, LET ME GIVE YOU ONE
EXAMPLE.
I LOVE OUR MILITARY.
IT'S GOT CIVILIAN LEADERSHIP.
IT'S EMBARRASSING.
LOOK AT THE TWITTER PAGE.
THEY HAVE VIDEO AFTER VIDEO
ABOUT THE PROPER USE OF
PRONOUNS.
NO, YOU NEED TO BE FOCUSED ON
HOW DO WE BLOW UP CHINESE
AIRCRAFT CARRIERS IF THEY EVER
ATTACK US?
OF COURSE THEY DON'T RESPECT
THE GUY.
THEY DON'T RESPECT HIM.
WHY WOULD THEY?
AND SO I THINK THEY VIEW HIM
AS INCOMPETENT.
THEN I THINK YOU SEE, OK, IF
YOU'RE BAD TO AMERICA AND MEAN
TO BIDEN, HE'LL TRY TO BE NICE
TO YOU.
YOU'RE ACRAN OR VENEZUELA,
HE'LL WANT TO DO A DEAL -- IF
YOU'RE IRAN OR VENEZUELA,
HE'LL WANT TO DO A DEAL.
IF YOU'RE JOHN KERRY, HE'S
LIKE THE CHARLIE CRIST OF THE
VETERAN ERA --
>> Sean: WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
THIS SHOW ON THE ROAD.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> CHINA IS SITTING THERE
SAYING WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
THESE GUYS TO THE CLEANER.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT'S DANGEROUS AND RECKLESS
AND THE CHINA THREAT IS THE
THREAT OF THE 21ST CENTURY.
EITHER THEY'LL BE THE WORLD'S
MOST POWERFUL COUNTRY OR WE
WILL.
I PROMISE YOU, A WORLD WHERE
CHINA IS THE POST POWERFUL
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD IS NOT
THE ONE I WANT TO LEAVE MY
KIDS.
>> Sean: I H